et bien bonjour comment ça va
aujourd'hui comment est ce que vous
allez j'espère vous allez bien j'ai
quand tout se passe bien pour vous vous
avez la santé la pêche à la grosse
patate tout va bien alors aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler d'un sujet je tourne
cette vidéo on va être quasiment début
avril 2022 je voulais regarder un petit
peu des gens derrière chaque s'il est un
peu tôt mais il est tellement de choses
de sortie je voulais regarder un peu ce
qui s'était passé sur ces trois premiers
mois de l'année janvier février mars et
trois premiers mois de l'année d'après
il ya eu pas mal de lancement il ya eu
pas mal de choses et enfin il ya déjà eu
tout ça on smartphones je pense que vous
allez bien là j'ai fait tellement mal
qu'il a déjà eu combien 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 20 et
les fans de sortie d'un téléphone je
pense y en a eu d'autres mais bon moi je
vous parle déjà d'un téléphone de sortie
et dans ces vins là il y en a qui s'est
vraiment détaché quand j'ai trouvé un
cran au dessus alors il y en a assez du
courant et vous savez les marques
surtout le temps des produits et en
ressortir des produits il faut sortir
des produits parce qu'il faut deux
présents parce qu'il faut un catalogue
parce qu'il faut une nouvelle gamme ça
en fait beaucoup mais il en faut donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous êtes
toujours vachement de référence mais
y'en a plein ils sont pas plus bompas
plus mauvais ils sont juste là pour être
là pour proposer des smartphones un peu
pour tout le monde parce que là pour
tous les prix et c'est normal alors il
est évident que le produit dont je vous
parlais qui m'a le plus plu c'est plutôt
dans le haut du panier parce qu'elle
l'innovation et parce que c'est par là
justement où via l'innovation elle qui
arrivent ensuite les années suivantes
dans les smartphones d'entrée afin de
milieu de gamme puis ensuite d'entrée de
gamme mais y en a je trouve ça comme un
peu au dessus du lot une marque un kick
innove et qui se détache un peu
l'histoire source intéressante donc on
va regarder aujourd'hui parmi tous ces
téléphones qui ont été présentés déjà
début 2000 22 c est de voir vers lequel
retail plus son attention tout de suite
un instant tête ans on a d'autres qui
vont arriver donc je n'ai pas encore
tout vu j'en ai vu un paquet donc on se
regarde ça et puis je compte sur vous
pour me dire ce que vous en pensez en
bas
[Musique]
allez on y va ces parties où le mec il
ses plus beaux arrêts qui ont mais pas
ce n'est pas un poisson pourri j'étais
impatiente et je vois réellement de
l'eau parce que l'eau c'est la vie comme
dit jean claude van damme le borloo dans
20 30 ans il n'y aura plus alors on va
commencer à peu par ordre chronologique
de toutes mes vidéos si vous les avez
pas vu je dois dire voir mes vidéos sur
ma chaîne pourquoi lorsqu'elles sont
cools et que c'est moi qui les a fait se
contente d'un prêt alors on a commencé
l'année avec le galaxy s 21 un tarif
pardon s-21 et feu bon plutôt
intéressante a effectivement lu celui du
s1 effet qu'on avait vu arriver un an et
demi avant il arrive un peu tard
téléphone mais plutôt bien donc oui je
vais rien lui reprocher je trouve
intéressant effectivement bon il se
positionne plutôt bien il a plein de
jolies qualité mais c'est pas le truc le
plus révolutionnaire du monde mais il
est bien il est très complet il marche
bien donc là tu pas de souci ensuite je
suis parti aux crs à vegas et un truc
que j'ai trouvé ça marrant c'est s&l
chicago la spéciale chicago honnêtement
c'est une copie du z flip 3 de samsung
version tcl c'est pas un smartphone qui
sortira parce qu'il est trop cher par
rapport aux tarifs que voudrait mettre
tcl donc c'est un proto voilà c'est trop
et perd 1,1 me tous c'est à dire une
copie d'un premier modèle bon voilà il
n'a rien d'exceptionnel c'est assez
marrant j'ai vu un smartphone ce qui me
fâche man est un essai j'ai trouvé bien
c'est le haut pour le fine aide alors le
finder c'est pas smartphones qui va
sortir en france il est réservé
uniquement à l'asie mais c'est un
smartphone qui vachement intéressant
pourquoi et bien parce que c'est un
nouveau format de pliable souvenez vous
c'est l'espèce de pliable un peu carré
avec un nouveau format vraiment vraiment
bien la plus dure on la voit quasiment
pas et ça c'est une des innovations
qu'on va retrouver vachement
je vais pas jouer nettoie plus visage je
voudrais pas que vous ayez les yeux
salle c'est en fait une techno qu'on va
les voir arriver de plus en plus en 2022
ou c'est sur les écrans qu'ils puissent
à dire le fait de parrot pliure de la
voie moins en moins il a brillé quand
même pas mal sur les smartphones des
générations précédentes mais bon voilà
faute de mieux c'est ce qu'on avait donc
c'était bien mais là on voit arriver
pour la des espèces de save et des
technologies goutte d'eau ça vient se
plier où on sent quasiment pu appliquer
parce que ça vient plus plier l'écran ça
vient plus fins et donc il ya plus
vraiment c'est pire il ya une figure
bien évidemment mais elle est amoindrie
donc low profile être vachement
intéressant deux pages format de par le
fait que la pliure commencé vraiment
disparaître etc et vu notre proposition
dans l'univers du puits alors c'est
parce martin qui va arriver une fois de
plus je vous le dis donc on le regarde
un peu rapidement mais l'innovation m'a
plu et j'ai trouvé ça chouette du point
de vue des opposants lorsqu'on a vu
arriver le triptyque galaxy s 22 aces de
plus s 22 autres sont des mails mise à
jour tous les ans voir arriver de
nouvelles mises à jour le smartphone qui
va vraiment bluffé ici or ce n'est pas
celui qui m'a le plus bluffé de toute la
liste mais celui qui va bien bluffés ici
c'est le s 22 ultra pourquoi est-ce que
le f-22 ultra m'a vachement bluffer sur
toute la partie photo de nuit et vidéos
de lui alors vous savez des fois les
constructeurs il prouve achement poussé
et je vous l'avais déjà dit notamment
avec china dernière avec le ct lequel
c'était le midd 11 ultra il faisait
presque jour c'est à dire qui à un
moment on va un peu loin et là c'est
pareil ils vont très très loin
clairement ici samsung avec le f-22
ultra si vous n'avez pas vu ma vidéo et
je vous invite à venir la voir sur la
night au graffiti l'empreinte de
fonctionner quasiment pas lumière petit
filet mais il fait nuit quoi et ça vous
sort des photos comme en plein jour
alors pas exactement parce qu'on n'est
pas saturé de la même manière mais pour
autant le résultat extrêmement bluffant
donc assez cool ce smartphone là il
avait aussi une particularité qui était
super intéressant c'est que je sais pas
si vous vous souvenez on va revenir en
arrière on revient en août 2000 20 août
2020 c'est le dernier galaxy note que
samsung a sorti et y'en a pas de sortie
en 2021 est donc là effectivement ce s22
ultra y vient enterrer cette gamme note
il vient apporter dans la gamme s les
modèles ultra est bien la productivité
qu'on n'allait pas dans cette gamme là
donc c'est un smartphone qui qui qui
montre le virage des gamins petit peu de
femmes souffrent tous les deux cette
gamme là chez samsung et de ce modèle là
donc ça c'est aussi chouette avoir donc
un smartphone un peu différent qui
raconte une fois une nouvelle histoire
était une fois de plus que très gros
boulot qu'ils ont fait ici au niveau de
la photo en vidéo il est très cool aussi
attention vidéo nuisent un peu moins ça
mes vidéos en plein jour c'est un
excellent photophone enfin vidéophone on
peut dire mais la nuit ça m'a vraiment
bluffé ça c'était un des plus beaux
smartphones que j'ai pu voir cette année
mais un peu fade aussi attention ils
soient formatées quand même un peu un
peu gros après on arrive en haut de
gamme arythmie note 11 à voulant là je
vous ai montré notamment mwc vous en
avez tous les côtés attention et demi de
trompes préfère une farandole avec
tellement quel smartphone bon il n'ya
pas grand chose ne soit racontée ici on
est dans l'entrée milieu de gamme ok
pareil pour un one plus notre ce2 on est
dans cette gabla c'est pas mal
smartphone plutôt cool lourimi neuf pros
plus je sais pas s'il réunit aujourd'hui
arrive vraiment à faire sa place sur le
marché pas si vous avez achetez vous un
smartphone de rim il propose des
produits vachement intéressant il ya des
trucs super intéressant mais ça avec le
marché tellement saturé que c'est c'est
pas hyper évident mais les produits sont
là la marque est là et les produits sont
cool moi je vous en parle je trouve bien
aux produits que j'ai vu arriver doter
de ce type au col x 4 pro 5 g et le m4
au 4g ok pareil ils viennent dans la
bagarre il apprend compte pas une
histoire complètement folle de la
performance pour le gaming mais bon au
delà de ça pas grand chose aux
smartphones c'est juste une première
prise en main une présentation parce
qu'il n'est pas encore arrivé tout de
suite donc on n'en parlera plus tard
c'est au nord au nord a fait son grand
retour là où on va dire l'année dernière
en france mais en fait ils sont séparés
de huawei ils ont récupéré les services
google et ils reviennent avec de
nouveaux produits alors il ya les
ordinateurs il ya les montes ya les
écouteurs il ya les smartphones mais
autant quand il était avec avec huawei
c'était la marque jeune de huawei autant
aujourd'hui c'est plus la pac jeunes de
huawei pour se marrer
pas été bon en fait aujourd'hui au nord
c'est une marque à part entière qui elle
par contre travaille très bien ces
produits on l'a vu nous ont montré un
smartphone pliable que je lui déjà pris
en main et j'ai testé j'ai découvert ici
à des groupes donc été vachement
intéressant et c'est une marque qui va
falloir regarder très très près parce
qu'à mon avis ils vont envoyer du pâté
ils ont l'innovation sont très très gros
moyens et c'est vraiment une marque
lacie dont on en reparlera ce magic cap
proche de trouver intéressant parce que
sur le très haut de gamme c'était la
première fois qu'on a vu arriver en tout
cas en france ici parce qu avait déjà eu
un magic 3 promet ce n'est pas comme
pour chez nous c'était pour lâcher donc
le magic 4 pro à mon avis et c'est le
début vraiment de l'histoire de honor en
france et en europe sur le très haut de
gamme donc c'est en tout cas suivre et
on verra aux smartphones que j'ai vu
c'est le one + 10 pro alors le one + 10
proches très très partagés parce que je
le trouve plutôt sympa mais je trouve
tellement en dessous en photo quand je
les ai eues sur la version de test je
pense à sa logique une mise à jour
logicielle vient de corriger un peu ça
parce que la commune est là c'est pas
tout à fait sascha omis 12 6 ème et 12
pro plutôt joli aussi belle innovation
j'attends le chien milou ultras qui n'a
pas qu'annoncer ici à soyons clairs mais
c'est vraiment le smartphone que
j'attendrais pour pouvoir ensuite
arrivés au bout de ma soif de ma faim
pour les smartphones haut de gamme de
chimie de cette année parce que je
trouve cool intentions je trouve super
coup j'ai trois fautes au niveau du
professionnel surtout mai
dit c'est pas possible qu'on ait pas un
ultra revient chez envies peuvent aller
beaucoup plus loin en termes
d'innovation en termes de savoir faire
en termes de photos qui peuvent aller
beaucoup aussi bien ce qu'ils font
attention c'est très bien sûr le chili
12 promet je m'attends encore autre
chose quoi je sais qu'ils peuvent nous
surprendre douja temps un modèle ultra
j'espère qu'il arrivera on verra ça j'ai
vu également paltrow galaxie à 33
galaxie à 53 hockey est intéressant
c'est pareil on se positionne ici dans
la fenêtre de tir je sais pas comment on
peut dire ça de tous les smartphones
avec 1 à 53 qui va se vendre énormément
cette année parce que c'est un très joli
modèle et que c'est toujours les modèles
qu'ils ont de plus et samsung donc
plutôt bien et rien de bien surprenant
une belle mise à jour aussi du côté de
l'iphone et ce avec les fans et ceux de
2022 troisième génération comme vous
voulez qui est bien qu'ils apportent la
5g qu'elle la performance tu es bien
voilà il ya pas des faits - ou sur cet
iphone l'a clairement mais il est bien
il vient renouveler la gamme donc voilà
ça c'est plutôt bien et puis je dirais
que les smartphones qui montrent plus
bluffé bouteilles d'eau il faut boire
l'eau c'est important l'eau c'est la vie
comme la mise en place
et jean claude van damme mois les
smartphones qui m'ont vraiment marqué
alors il y en a un qui m'a marqué là il
en reste deux en fait dans la liste et
c'est drôle parce que c'est ce que je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure au niveau de
l'innovation séché au pot le finepix
actu trouvé bien ok pas de problème très
très bien mais le finepix high point
j'ai trouvé très bien attention pas
parfait pas parfait parce que pas de
stabilisation optique au niveau d'un tel
objectif alors que c'est justement ce
qu'il faut je dirais tel objectif ça
bouge c'est que la stam numérique c'est
naze et là c'est un peu dommage j'étais
vraiment que cette attaque était en
dessous mais titre le smartphone
vachement bien bossé j'ai trouvé très
cool le partenariat car emmenait one
plust vous savez wyplosz ils sont fait
partie du même groupe que copeaux mais
là ils sont vraiment rapproché de 2o
powell pluzz parce que bon faut dire que
ça n'est pas trop trop trop et que du
coup aujourd'hui bon alors et quand ils
sont rapprochés ils ont ramené à ce bled
chez au pot et je trouve ça assez drôle
parce que pour voir courir soit deuxième
version d'un seul bug au niveau de oued
place avec le one + 10 pro ne guérit la
nature une puce neuf pros c'était la
première collaboration fait qu'un seul
blaise c'était bien la vraie réussite
cette année que le partenariat castle
blake c'est pas si loin de pluzz qu'ils
l'emmenaient pourtant sur la première
génération et la syrie sur sa deuxième
dans ces copeaux avec son find x5 pro et
avec le boulot qu'ils ont fait castle
blade ar ça marche mais vraiment fort
les photos sont superbes elle est là ça
raconte une belle histoire et ça ça me
plaît parce que c'est un smartphone qui
est fatalement extrêmement performant la
dernière puce plus au diable sanary il
maîtrise très bien aussi toute la partie
software avec kolo est ce qui est super
bien on a super smartphone pour la photo
pour le gaming et très bien fait ma
fille très équilibré il n'est pas
parfait je pense que au pot a du boulot
encore sur un fail d'ixis pro l'année
prochaine pour dire tout stabiliser au
niveau des optiques parce qu'à un moment
il faut arrêter de déconner un jeu
diamant et l'état smartwatch plus il a
mille cent ou mille deux cents euros et
que tout n'est pas stabilisé alors moi
je trouve un nom fatalement ça se voit
encore plus mais ce smartphone live
vachement bluffé parce que j'ai trouvé
que il ya une montée en gamme chez au
pot c'est une marque qui est vachement
sous-estimé qui est assez méconnu en
fait elle commence est vachement plus
connus sont vachement travaillé depuis
des années ils sont mis en place sur le
sport notamment avec roland garros
besoin partenariat fort et cette marque
est beau c l envie est en fait c'est un
acteur qui est déjà très très fort en
chine qui monte en europe qui monte en
france et on le voit avec la smart phone
comme ça toute la puissance qui à skis
ou ça c'est énorme alors on se dira par
rapport à effectivement un f-22 ultra
est ce que il lui met une énorme gifle
la réponse est non mais si vous voulez
de voir arriver cette énorme évolution
sur les années avec au pot on se dit
qu'il ya un truc qui est dingue et on
l'a vu avec léopold faye haine avec ce
format du pliable un peu différent c'est
pas comme tcl qui a fait avec le chicago
un truc qui était très similaire aux
aides fold oz flip 3 par an c'est autre
chose is enough il propose autre chose
et encore il avait montré l'année
dernière fois d'année une usine au days
un système de caméras qui allait
effectivement bouger pour pouvoir
travailler au niveau de l'optique ils
ont montré beaucoup de choses au niveau
de la réalité mixte de la réalité
augmentée ils ont montré pas mal de
choses avec une caméra sous l'écran que
je trouvais aussi bluffante alors pour
autant la caméra sous l'écran on l'a
déjà vu chez samsung on l'a déjà vu chez
zte puisqu'une technologique on trouvera
un peu partout parce qu'il va
s'industrialiser et que tout le monde va
venir dessus mais il ya ce côté
innovation et qu'on retrouve ici dans
ses smartphones donc c'est pour ça que
pour moi dans ses trois premiers mois de
l'année 2022 le smartphone qui m'a le
plus bluffé c'est le au pot find x5 pro
pas dire qu'ils ne sont pas bien je vous
le dis une fois de plus j'ai beaucoup
aimé le travail de cinq sont notamment
avec le f-22 ultras qui m'a le plus
bluffé mais le reste eh bien on y est là
il reste de la mêlée si vous voulez où
on a plein de plein de jolis produits il
ya celui là qui se détache même s'il ya
là derrière qui colle un peu au basket
parce que ils sont très sympas donc
voilà ça c'est vraiment un truc que je
voulais dire parce que je crois que ce
smartphone il ya eu un très joli travail
et qu'il est cool pour autant et je vous
le dis une fois de plus si vous voulez
aller sur un samsung galaxy s 22 plus sa
semaine de travail
de très cool ils sont super bien et je
vous ai de liga des smartphones j'y
trouve un peu moins bien réussi il y en
a qui sont biens qui sont là qui sont
des renouvellements de gamme mais bon
ils sont pas non plus extraordinaire
mais là c'est cool ils sont bien bossé
donc voilà félicitations il pas ce que
vous en pensez ce que vous êtes d'accord
est ce que je vous dis est-ce que vous
avez achetés notamment low profile mix
funk 10,5 pro peut-être est-ce que vous
les avez ce que vous en êtes satisfait
ou pas du tout et qu'est ce que vous
pensez un peu de tous ces smartphones
qu'on a vu depuis le début de l'année
est un qui a retenu votre attention plus
que les autres et ce gamin qui vous
plaît davantage que les autres ou alors
pas du tout 1 on s'est pas dites le moi
en bas en commentaire les commentaires
sont faits pour ça moi je vous embrasse
faut demander vous très bientôt on va
continuer bien évidemment apparaître
smartphone parce qu'à plein de
nouveautés à plein de jolis produits
sont encore là la voyez ce coup sous les
yeux je vous ai pas encore présenté qui
va arriver et il y en a plein qui vont
arriver donc c'est plutôt chouette et
qu'on parle de smartphones et d'autres
choses parce que les smartphones n'y a
pas que des smartphones et ça c'est bien
allez prenez soin de vous nous
embrassant race et vos amis votre
famille de ma part et peut retour très
bientôt